à parler comme monsieur yves censi merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à jean marc ayrault monsieur
le ministre des affaires étrangères vos
successeurs à matignon manuel valls et
bernard cazeneuve ont pris l'habitude
d'évoquer ici les déclarations entendues
dans la campagne présidentielle
pourquoi pas mais si vous êtes membre
d'un gouvernement socialiste
vous êtes encore ministre de la france
et tout le monde s'interroge sur
l'absence de réaction du gouvernement
après la déclaration délirante de
monsieur macron à la télévision
algérienne je cite la colonisation
française est un crime contre l'humanité
certes nos compatriotes comprennent
aujourd'hui que la seule ambition de
l'inspecteur des finances socialiste
transformer en télévangéliste se résume
déclarations après déclaration a sondé
le vide
il pourrait s'agir d'une macro nahd
supplémentaire car nul n'est besoin d'en
dénoncer la stupidité sur le plan
historique surtout c'est une insulte
profonde grave et inadmissible fait à
notre pays
l'expression crimes contre l'humanité
est défini à l'article 6 de la charte de
londres établissant le statut du
tribunal de nuremberg
cette grave accusation est celle d'un
crime imprescriptible qui outragent de
gaulle et des gouvernements français qui
diffament le nom de chaque soldat
français mort pour la france en afrique
du nord qui attaque la dignité de toutes
les familles de harkis et de pieds-noirs
et de rapatriés qui ravale tous les
anciens combattants ont recueilli devant
nos stèle au rendent complices de crimes
contre l'humanité et de barbarie
passibles de traduction devant un
tribunal pénal international monsieur le
ministre il est inadmissible que ce
spécialiste du baiser de judas puisqu'il
aime les comparaisons christique
viennent ainsi cracher viennent ainsi
cracher sur nos tombes falsifier
l'histoire et déshonoré la france
monsieur le ministre vous avez été
premier ministre
vous avez le sens de l'état et celui de
l'histoire de france c'est à vous de
restaurer la dignité de nos compatriotes
à lormes agressions etc
secrétaire d'état chargé des affaires
européennes
[Musique]
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
monsieur le député yves censi la france
est liée à l'algérie de par son histoire
il ya également de très profonds liens
humains culturels qui lie nos deux pays
le passé colonial a été brutale et
tragique mais l'enjeu aujourd'hui c'est
celui de la paix des mémoires
l'algérie est un partenaire important de
la france un partenaire politique est un
partenaire économique
il nous faut aujourd'hui construire un
avenir commun et c'est dans cette
démarche que s'inscrit pile actions du
président de la république et du
gouvernement
dès 2012 françois hollande s'est rendu
en algérie
la déclaration d'alger sur l'amitié la
coopération entre la france et l'algérie
signés lors de cette visite a été suivie
de la mise en place d'un comité
intergouvernemental de haut niveau et
d'un comité mixte économique franco
algérien c'est en renforçant notre
coopération dans tous les domaines avec
l'algérie que nous contribuerons à la
peine et mémoire et je crois que tous
ici nous devons nous consacrer à ses
relations indispensable pour nos deux
pays pour la méditerranée entre la
france et l'algérie je vous remercie
merci monsieur un même désir là